تدريبات عسكريه جديده للقوات الاوكرانيه
في المانيا من قبل الجيش الامريكي حوالي
500 جنديا اوكراني سيخضعون لتدريبات
للعوده الى ساحه المعركه في حربهم ضد
الروس وافكار رئيسيه هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه الجنرال ماركلي
البرنامج التدريبي الذي لم يتم تحديده
موعده بشكل رسمي حتى الان بحسب البنتاجون
سيجرى في منطقه جرافيفر لمده تتراوح بين
خمسه الى ثمانيه اسابيع البرنامج جاهدف
الى صقلي مهارات القوات الاوكرانيه حتى
تكون مستعده لشنه هجوم او مواجهه اي هجمه
الروسيه بشكل افضل مع توفير مجموعه كامله
من الاسلحه الجديده والمعدات لهم في
المانيا لاستخدامها بحسب وكاله سوشي
الامريكيه
مجموعه الاسلحه الجديده والمدفعيه
والدبابات المتجهه الى اوكرانيا ستكون
مفتاحا لمساعده القوات كيف على استعاده
الاراضي التي استولت عليها روسيا في الحرب
المستمره منذ 11 شهرا
تسليم جميع الاسلحه والمعدات الوارده الى
اوكرانيا في وقت ما قبله طول امطار الربيع
لتتمكن القوات المدربه حديثا من استخدامها
تركيز الولايات المتحده منصبنا على تدريب
وتزويد القوات الاوكرانيه باحتياجاتها
الاكثر الحاحا في ساحه المعركه حيث قامت
واشنطن بالفعل بتدريبي اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
ومئه جنديا اوكراني حتى الان رشا خياط
العربيه